hello there i'm gab i'm dan we're the
slo-mo guys today we're revisiting a
video that i did a few years ago and by
few i mean 11.
they're longer yeah oh my god that's
almost embarrassing i'm embarrassed yeah
do you remember the video yeah you
weren't in it i wasn't in it
there was enough mugs in that video
without me hey basically what i did is i
printed different frame rates on
different mugs just to show like a
comparison of different frame rates and
it ended
at 10 000 frames a second i think
technology's come on quite a bit in 11
years we've made some advances in frame
rate so we'll be starting at 10 000 in
this one and today we're not smashing
mugs we're shooting eggs so we're here
at a firing range in the middle of
nowhere where it's safe to fire a nine
millimeter bullet
through some eggs yeah these are the
whitest eggs i've ever seen they look
like my butt in the winter
except less hairy all right let's get
cracking
literally i like it i like it this is
the phantom tmx 7510 it's appeared on
the channel before the current fastest
phantom in the world ah 10 000 frames a
second egg is downrange we're set for 10
000 frames 5 microsecond exposure
typically you want to be
10 or below for a sharp bullet and this
is not the fastest bullet in the world
so we should be fine at 5.
loading
made ready
aiming
egg bloody went just disappeared
for reference this normal speed camera
is recording at 50 frames a second and
it didn't even see the bullet it was in
and out in less than a fiftieth of a
second not visible on a single frame
it's just gone
see ya how sharp is the bullet though
pretty sharp pretty nice not bad is it
yeah i mean it's definitely motion blur
still
i'm surprised that how much of the
eggshell stayed intact maybe it was just
too quick for it to even break you know
what i'm excited to see at the higher
frame rates is it it's the tiny you see
on the entrance wound yeah and the exit
wind is the tiny pieces of shell that
are all like of a similar size that's
gonna be really interesting right now
yeah that is cool all right let's not
waste too much time at the uh lower
frame rates let's get up there
i'm just going to double but let's just
go straight to 50 000 on this one it's
hard to write on an egg
you've got uh excellent handwriting
thanks b
mine's shocking actually it's so bad
mine's really bad too i haven't had to
write anything for years everyone always
told me i should be a doctor because
i've got rubbish handwriting everyone
always told me i should be a doctor and
then they realized i was an idiot
[Laughter]
but not when it comes to weapons
yeah it's gradually taking up more of
the
shooting time that we have the higher
frame rate
look at the spin you definitely see the
rifling oh you do you just you didn't
notice that before did we
no 10 000 wasn't fast enough to see that
rifling clearly
nice right through perfect it was
tumbling as soon as it came out the egg
there just an eggshell that means we
should probably at the end of this then
see how many eggs it can get through
it'd just be doing back flips through
the eggs i wonder if it slowed it down
any as well
i must have yeah
i keep leaning on this as if i'm
expecting it not to be covered
okay doubling
100 000. my gran used to
sort of try and hatch chickens
and she used to give the
eggs a kiss that's like a good luck
but actually
all that does is um impart bacteria onto
the eggshell which then goes into the
into the actual egg itself because
they're not you know they're porous ah
so don't suck on eggs
you were teaching your gran to not suck
on eggs i wasn't teaching her she was
just doing what she wanted
okay i've lowered the vertical
resolution
to 576.
no longer at 720p a bit narrower went
out 100 000 frames a second
made ready
oh there's an egg on my leg
i love videos of this it's just
absolutely what cameras like this before
so slow now
straight through i feel like that egg
got shattered more maybe maybe it was
just slightly more frontal it was just
more closer towards the towards the
camera i said i don't know maybe
and then as the egg clears here you can
see like an upward splash you see that
yeah the over pressure of the egg and
that's what got me is the egg from the
cup must have flung around and hit my
leg yeah and it just span like loads of
yolk on my leg
there you go that's what that's the egg
that's on my leg can't i can't get
enough to say in that yeah you love it
little what
oh it's the shock the
shockwave wow
that is fast that's going to be really
i wonder if that was visible on the
frontal because it is casting a shadow
you see like the air is like a different
density that the the light is like
yeah it's like fractured bending through
yeah so there's actually a shadow from
the nothing you know if the
larger the frame rate goes you you're
going to have run of run out of egg room
it's true i'm going to have to short i'm
going to turn my font size down okay 200
000 frames a second vertical resolution
is now two five six
it's a long slit of a frame exposure
time two and a half microseconds not
long that's two and a half millionths of
a second
whoa
oh
that's so slow leisurely
this is carrying an egg on it i wonder
if that eggshell's spinning or whether
it's just pasted to the front
shock wave
bouncy shot wave you can see the the
shape of the bullet better now you see
it's got like a concave back to it you
can see all the turbulent airflow behind
the bullet too and the air around the
back of the bullet is now being pulled
in to fill that void so it's sort of
sucking egg into the trail of the bullet
look at the like tiny tiny tiny pieces
of shell that come out there
missed it
that is a nice frame rate for a nine
millimeter and that's a slow slow bullet
too
yeah
wow
that is so cool
400 000
that's your neatest one yet so we've
gone from basically this as our
resolution yep to this
flip which means i've had to
pull the phantom back which is giving us
like this you've gone like five feet
back at least yeah by a million frames a
second you'll be the next town i'll be
uh yeah georgetown yeah
our exposure time is now
1.25 microseconds
oh
oh that is that is a nats
bollock of uh
framing there isn't it
here we come
so slow
there's like a little puff of mist that
happens on impact that comes back
i think it comes back like faster than
the bullets it does
by the time it's in the in the egg it's
already past the back of the bullet
it's like it's stolen a bit of egg again
i bet there's some eggshell in the sand
wow good shot it's not easy to keep the
bullet in frame the entire way
it's interesting how many shadows from
shock waves we're seeing typically you
get one from the expansion of gas coming
out of the front of the barrel and then
a second one as the bullet comes out i'm
not 100 sure but we could possibly be
seeing one of those shock waves for a
second time as it bounces off the table
all right i'm gonna have to change lens
here because this is
a f 2.8
which won't do it for us when we're sub
microsecond exposure time
b can you just hold your hand over the
sensor yeah bear with me
switching to a slightly wider prime
benefit of a lens that doesn't zoom is
that typically
a wider aperture
good bit of knowledge hey good bit of
knowledge that yeah yeah didn't know
that you're writing extra big now well
the resolution's so low that i'm
i'm trying to make it legible in there
yeah i think my each letter is only
going to be like 10 pixels high
look at this look at this framing
what
right to keep it in i'm gonna have to
shoot perfectly flat
should i should we come back in and just
do like no no no that's fine well aside
from when we went to caltech and shot 10
trillion frames a second this is now the
fastest we filmed using phantoms 800 000
frames a second with an exposure time
lower than a microsecond that is
625 nanoseconds
for an exposure and uh it's just a tiny
slit so this will be very interesting
uh this should actually be
too slow for this bullet
resolution
1280x64
what a shot
is it perfectly through you nailed that
a little bit of muzzle flash too
look at it here it comes
let's think of it isn't the egg still
just sort of breezed past it that time
oh no it is tumbling you see look
got a bit of wobble too isn't it yeah
that is so immensely slow i wouldn't say
it was tumbling but it's definitely
wobbly on it's on its own of accesses
i mean
that's definitely
we're now beyond useful speeds
yeah
but you know
this thing could do a billion
it's a nice round number isn't it a
million is a nice number so
oh you've got a new egg there that was
well confusing why don't we go why would
it go live
so i said in the intro that it'll do a
million in black and white and i say
that because
shooting a million
non-black and white
gives you a height of 32 pixels which
it's pretty
you're not gonna see much are you okay
here's a brief explanation of the pixel
binning feature of this camera it will
change how the sensor operates and use
four pixels as one so i'll take a two by
two grid of pixels treat it as one which
effectively reduces the horizontal
resolution by half so we're now at 640
but because it's a two by two grid we're
still using the entire width of the
sensor the vertical resolution can also
be the equivalent of 128 pixels high
once again in a 2x2 grid giving us a
complete resolution of 640 by 64
but at the same aspect ratio as 1280
by 128. this mode ditches all color
information but increases the
sensitivity on the sensor so now we need
less light for shooting at such short
duration exposures we're basically at
the same aspect ratio that we were when
we were shooting at 400 000 frames a
second but we can now go a million and
above so a slight trade-off but a much
more usable image ah it says been off on
the camera just has been off it just
makes me think i thought it was like
delete
[Laughter]
so now look i've got it done look it's
done i've got much more height okay
one mf
slash s million frames a second 500
nanosecond exposure time 640 by 64. and
you can see that it's it's uh a taller
image than before even though we're
shooting faster there is now no color of
course and actually a nicely exposed egg
i think it actually hits home harder
writing the word million though i think
it has more of an effect 1 million
frames a second
i almost said in 4k but it's not
close one day though we'll redo this
when we can do a million frames a second
in 4k yeah that'll be when this the sun
starts dying and expanding and getting
brighter
interestingly of all the bullet hits
that our normal speed camera captured
today this is the only clip where a
single frame of bullet is visible
this blurred streak
safe
cheers
come on you can see the pixels
yeah
there's not many no
but think about it this is like a
science research camera
you could learn a lot from this footage
it's not necessarily broadcast quality
but about eggs
well
you probably wouldn't be looking at eggs
look at that it's so slow
getting bored
i'm getting bored i never thought
watching a bullet go through the screen
would be like watching paint dry just
just let me know when it's there that's
that says so much about this it can make
bullets too slow i love it is it there
yet it's almost there ah there you go
all right i caught me too early
sorry here we go
wow that just like slowly goes in is
that there's so much time separation
between the impact and when it sort of
spews stuff out backwards we filmed so
slow that we got several seconds there
where the bullet was inside the egg
it's several seconds i think at 10 000
it was in there for about a frame yeah
if that i mean this is slower by a
factor of 100 than 10 000 yeah oh yeah
it's still slightly your usually i'm
like 100 times slower than real time
it's 100 times slower than 10 thousand
there we go very impressive
all right lastly i thought we could have
five firstly just to see if the bullet
will even stay straight and go through
five eggs and also i feel like in
descending order i'll write the
different frame rates and then in post
change to those speeds and i figured
we'd start with the highest frame rate
because
by the time it's here if it gets here
the bullet will be slower anyway so if
it's 10 here that's probably fine if the
bullet is really slow at that point i
like it so we'll do 4 2
1 50 10.
these were thousands by the way oh okay
oh hundred thousand 100 000 okay based
on the tumblage i think we'll struggle
to hit all five eggs you think yeah
well one after one it does tumble but
there's still a hell of a lot of power
and speed going behind it so
some confidence yeah i think it'll get
through five right
no
never
where'd it go did it go high it's hard
to say
maybe i just missed maybe it just went
like behind or up yeah potentially it's
this just about there's nothing of the
first four nothing of the first four not
a scratch
well you know what then
i think that egg deserves to live
okay
i'll keep it separate from the rest
wow cousin's blood on it
well
no need to get dark with it
they're unfertilized there wasn't a
chicken in there that's true bullets
coming in nice and slow at 400
[Music]
always sideways it's just going to clip
the top of that one
hit the back of 50 and oh
god let's do it
that egg is just like sweating profusely
look at the tumble at the end it's cause
like you know when you go on like a
say for instance you have your hand
outside the window yeah in it and it
does that like the air like it's the
same with the egg like the moisture in
the egg is pushing it
further and further so it misses the uh
this is the last one that's class
all right now let's take a look at that
at the respective speeds
well i thought some really interesting
looking footage it was honestly
fascinating to learn the speed where
this type of bullet becomes almost
leisurely in how long it takes to go
across the frame because we film most of
our stuff you know a thousand with the
other camera and you know maybe like 25
000 or 28 000 on the other one but
it's interesting to be up in the
hundreds of thousands and actually slow
a bullet all the way down and think well
that's the perfect speed for a bullet
any slower
boring yeah it gets boring after you hit
hit a mill gets a bit boring it takes
forever yeah it's also nice because we
were doing this experiment it
illustrates the different frame rates
perfectly because each time i fire the
gun the bullets are within a certain
tolerance going about the same speed
when they come out so it's nice to
illustrate here's your hero egg thank
you ten thousand frames a second
survives
um anyway if you enjoyed that video make
sure you subscribe that's a good catch
bloody
make sure you subscribe if you like
slobo send it to a friend if they might
find that interesting and we'll see you
next time for some more immensely slow
footage don't know what that was
actually what was that you want to keep
that yeah you're okay with that being
again
that's not well look take it this way
right
people
already
know and think that i'm a complete tall
nerd
me doing that isn't going to ruin my
street cred
do you know me it's not like it's not
like people are like oh i thought he was
cool before he did that we're already
wearing lab coats in a quarry look at
the state of me yeah
right it's not hurting me to do that so
yeah keep it keep it in keep it in
it's in
you're gonna leave that in yeah